[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen einen schönen
guten abend freut mich dass sie dabei
sind auch kristin otto hat ziemlich viel
sport im gepäck fußball vor allem
fußball genau genannt und wir blicken
jetzt gemeinsam auf die themen des tages
geht es ohne impfpflicht immer mehr
länder chefs fordern sie die ampel
parteien beraten mit der kanzlerin über
die korona lage
letzte vorbereitungen in den unternehmen
ab morgen gilt in ganz deutschland 3g am
arbeitsplatz
bittere bilanz zu gewalt in
partnerschaften im vergangenen jahr
haben die übergriffe deutlich zugenommen
bei uns wird immer lauter über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht diskutiert lange
haben spitzenpolitiker sie
ausgeschlossen aber inzwischen äußern
sich immer mehr ministerpräsidenten pro
impfpflicht das in einer situation in
der die korona zahlen immer weiter
ansteigen der handlungsdruck auf die
politik steigt vor allem auf die ampel
parteien die mit angela merkel bis eben
über die lage beraten haben patricia
wiedemeier
der andrang ist groß auch beim drive-in
impfen in köln heute doch noch immer ist
die impfquote zu gering die zahl der
infektionen steigt rasant weiter wenn
man mehr politiker fordern daher neue
maßnahmen jetzt den knall nicht gehört
hat dem kann man nicht mehr helfen da
müssen wir jetzt wirklich kreativ sein
und zu besseren lösungen kommen um noch
mehr menschen impfen zu können kreatives
impfen überall wo es möglich ist doch
das alleine reicht nicht die zahl derer
die jetzt eine allgemeine impfpflicht
fordern nimmt zu es ist eben eine frage
ob viele millionen menschen in ihrer
feier dauerhaft beschränkt werden müssen
weil einige andere für sich entscheiden
dass sie eine maßnahme nicht machen
natürlich gibt es eine spaltung der
gesellschaft ist doch keine frage ich
glaube dass eine impfpflicht dann
endlich so wie sie es immer war bei
solchen diskussionen
es gab auch schon in deutschland im
schlichten das dazu führt er das am ende
man ihr zusammenkommen weil es mal
entschieden ist politiker der künftigen
ampel koalition hatten sich bisher für
eine berufsspezifische impfpflicht
ausgesprochen zum beispiel nur für
pflegepersonal doch angesichts immer
hörer infektionszahlen wird nun auch
eine allgemeine impfpflicht nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen wenn sie kommt dann muss
ich aber sitzen und dann muss eben
besondere vor den gerichten bestand
haben und dafür ist ein nachweis dass
mildere mittel nicht zur verfügung
stehen sicherlich sehr sinnvoll es sind
zu wenige menschen geimpft und wir
kommen einfach nicht darum wenn die aus
diesem schlamassel rauskommen wollen
dass sich die menschen verlassen müssen
nur dann gewinnen wir unsere freiheit
wieder das ist der grund warum wir uns
für eine impfpflicht aussprechen offen
bleibt ob eine allgemeine impfpflicht
überhaupt rechtlich zulässig ist oder ob
sie kurzfristig hilft viele fragen die
wohl auch beraten wurden bei einem
treffen der künftigen ampelkoalition
ehre mit der geschäftsführenden
kanzlerin das vor wenigen minuten zu
ende ging
und wir fragen nach bei theo koll in
berlin theo die ampel parteien haben
also mit der noch kanzlerin bis eben
beraten was hören sie worauf könnte es
denn jetzt hinauslaufen es könnte auf
weitere drastische entscheidungen
herauslaufenden dieser termin heute
abend der ist so eine art leiser
politischer paukenschlag die spitzen der
ampel parteien also scholz lindner
habeck und bernburg wurden regelrecht
einbestellt von der geschäftsführenden
kanzlerin und wussten vorher
offensichtlich nicht einmal genau welche
corona vorschläge ist dabei gehen sollte
angela merkel hatte ja schon klar
gemacht dass sie die bisherigen gesetzes
maßnahmen für unzureichend hält wir
hören dass die grünen beispielsweise
über ein weiteres bundesgesetz reden
dass kurzfristig noch mal eine
weitgehende vollbremsung also auch
ausgangssperren erlauben würde wobei
fraglich ist ob die fdp das mittragen
würde eines ist jedenfalls sehr klar die
viren sind momentan deutlich stärker als
frühere politische versprechungen also
es könnte sein dass dieses abendliche
corona treffen noch überraschungen
bringt danke für die einschätzung theo
koll ja viele bundesländer verschärfen
deutlich ihre corona maßnahmen in den
meisten wurden für weite teile des
öffentlichen lebens zweig regeln
beschlossen in berlin gilt das auch für
den einzelhandel ausnahme die
grundversorgung in thüringen gibt es
auch eine nächtliche ausgangssperre für
ungeimpfte in brandenburg wird die
anwesenheitspflicht für schülerinnen und
schüler aufgehoben außerdem sollen die
weihnachts ferien drei tage früher
beginnen
wichtig natürlich auch heute der blick
auf die korona zahlen die weiter kräftig
steigen dem robert koch institut wurden
45.000 326 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden gemeldet das sind gut 13.000
mehr als vergangenen dienstag
309 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents liegt nur noch knapp
unter der 400er marke
geimpft gewesen oder getestet das müssen
nach dem reformierten
infektionsschutzgesetz ab morgen alle
sein die zum beispiel mit zügen und
bussen der deutschen bahn fahren und je
nach dem wie und wo sie arbeiten sollten
sie zum arbeitsbeginn auch etwas mehr
zeit einplanen
3 gilt von morgen an nämlich auch beim
job und dort müssen arbeitgeber jeden
tag kontrollieren und dokumentieren also
wer nicht geimpftes muss täglich einen
test vorlegen auch ein selbst test vor
ort ist zulässig bei verstößen drohen
den beschäftigten konsequenzen es gibt
dann keinen lohn über vorbereitungen und
probleme mit der neuen regelung
berichtet jetzt stefan schlosser
in der haustechnik firma baumstark in
wiesbaden wird die 3g regel schon seit
vergangener woche angewendet zusätzlich
werden an drei tagen alle in der firma
getestet wer nicht geimpft oder genießen
ist muss jetzt täglich einen
zertifizierten nachweis einer
teststation vorlegen ich habe gegen
angst zudem finde
nicht ganz gesund der arbeitet macht
nach hin keine probleme von den 90
mitarbeitern zensiert sind weder geimpft
noch genießen chef theo baumstark
begrüßt die neuregelung der druck wird
durch aufgebaut auch bei uns im
kundenkreis nicht gibt kunden die über
legen wert darauf dass nur noch
geimpften zu ihnen kommen große firmen
der altenheime sind dabei mittlerweile
und unsere kunden
für große unternehmen bedeuten die
kontrollen auch größeren aufwand bei der
er und v versicherung gehen zwar alle
die können es home office die anderen
müssen aber kontrolliert werden
es ist natürlich eine herausforderung
wir müssen für unsere bundesweit mehr
als 16.000
mitarbeiter an unterschiedlichen
standorten mit verschiedenen
gegebenheiten eine praktikable lösung
finden und da sind wir jetzt einfach mit
hochdruck daran das zu tun
zugangskontrollen sind im gespräch ob im
gebäude oder bereits davor hier ist das
noch nicht klar deutliche kritik aus der
reinigungsbranche 700.000 menschen
arbeiten hier schätzungsweise 30 prozent
davon ungefähr
200.000 mitarbeiter mitarbeiter die in
verschiedensten reinigungs sekten über
100.000 reinigungs objekten in
deutschland tätig sind zu verschiedenen
zeiten tätig sind das bedeutet für uns
logistisch und finanziell einer
erheblichen mehraufwand der auch nicht
wirklich zu leisten ist fraglich also ob
die regelung schon ab morgen so
konsequent und lückenlos angewendet
werden kann wie es die politik fordert
noch gibt es viel unsicherheit
ja und gut aussah attacke jetzt bei uns
ist unsere zdf rechtsexperte in alu
sarah also viele fragezeichen was die
umsetzung von 3g angerannt auch die
kontrolle was gilt denn jetzt also für
die arbeit niemals ganz klar sie müssen
kontrollieren und bei dem wie haben sie
einen relativ großen spielraum denn der
gesetzgeber hat auch erkannt dass
unternehmen nicht gleich unternehmen ist
sondern es sehr große unterschiede gibt
und wenn ein unternehmen zum beispiel
viele mitarbeiter die mobil arbeiten
gebäudereinigerhandwerk dann kann es
auch möglich sein dass ungeimpfte
mitarbeiter ihren täglichen test per
screenshot per whatsapp einfachen in
arbeitgeber schicken und am ende der
woche das ganze noch meinen papierform
dokumentieren grundsätzlich hat das
bundesarbeitsministerium aber gesagt ist
die kontrolle als zutrittskontrolle
gemeint das heißt am werkstor sollte
kontrolliert werden und für die
arbeitnehmer ist ganz wichtig tests zeit
ist keine arbeitszeit und sie müssen
sich um die tat selber kümmern und im
zweifel auch selber dafür zahlen ok aber
was passiert wenn arbeitnehmer wenn
arbeitgeber diese regel nicht befolgen
wie teuer wird richtig teuer bis zu
25.000 euro für arbeitgeber die nicht
kontrollieren und bis zu 25.000 euro für
arbeitnehmer mitarbeiter die ihren test
nicht bei sich führen was aber das
maximum wie arbeitnehmers aber noch mal
wichtig zu wissen wer nicht im home
office arbeiten kann und sich weigert im
test zu machen oder nachweis zu
erbringen der kann dann nicht arbeiten
muss dementsprechend auch nicht bezahlt
werden kann auch abgemahnt werden am
ende auch gekündigt werden das klingt
danach als müssen sich alle sehr
disziplinieren vielen dank
und soviel zum thema corona wo sich
weiter natürlich viel tut welche neuen
regeln gelten jetzt bei ihnen ob am
arbeitsplatz oder in der freizeit in
einem krone blog finden sie alle
aktuellen entwicklungen jederzeit online
in der zdf- heute- app
zu einem ganz anderen thema behörden
warnen dass liebe immer öfter in hass
und gewalt umschlägt stalking
vergewaltigung oder gar mord die zahlen
vom letzten jahr sind schockierend alle
zweieinhalb tage wurde in deutschland
eine frau von ihrem partner oder
ex-partner getötet zusammen
139 frauen in einem jahr insgesamt
wurden 20 20 mehr als 148 1000 menschen
opfer von häuslicher gewalt darunter in
seltenen fällen auch männer in der summe
liegt die dunkelziffer wohl deutlich
höher isabel de la vega mit einem
beispiel
sie ist mitte dreißig kommt aus algerien
und möchte nicht erkannt werden über
fünf jahre lang war sie verheiratet mit
einem mann der gewalttätig ist am anfang
noch lief ihre ehe normal als sie mit
den kindern nach deutschland kamen doch
dann geriet der mann in schwierigkeiten
mit seiner ex und im job
ich sollte plötzlich für alle probleme
büßen er bekam immer mehr zwei gesichter
ein freundliches und eines wie ein
diktator er wollte jeden schritt
kontrollieren mit wem ich auf der arbeit
sprechen sollte und mit wem nicht er
wurde immer aggressiver wegen nichts und
schlug mich dann auch
partnerschafts gewalt das ist in
deutschland ein wachsendes problem
eine studie des bka belegte in
zusammenhang mit corona diese deutet
darauf hin dass sich das risiko von
partnerschafts gewalt während der
heimquarantäne erhöht hat
stressfaktor mit kurzarbeit verlust des
arbeitsplatzes spielt mir sicherlich
eine rolle die telefonischen
beratungsstellen registrieren nicht nur
mehr anrufe von betroffenen sondern auch
ihrer nachbarn dass zum beispiel das
arbeiten im home office unter diesen
chor ohne bedingungen dazu führt dass
man viel mehr davon mitbekommt was in
der nachbarschaft passiert wenn es
streit gibt wenn es laut wird vielen
frauen fällt es schwer sich aus einer
solchen situation zu befreien
wohin sollte ich mit meinen kindern es
ging mir schlecht ich konnte ohne
tabletten nicht mehr schlafen ich hatte
auch panikattacken
als er anfing auch die kinder zu
schlagen bin ich endlich abgehauen der
36 jährigen gelang es mit hilfe einer
beratungsstelle sich scheiden zu lassen
und woanders ein neues leben anzufangen
ein katholischer priester aus dem
erzbistum köln muss sich seit heute vor
gericht verantworten
es geht um den vorwurf des sexuellen
missbrauchs von kindern er soll sich in
den neunziger jahren an seinen drei
nichten vergangen haben sie waren zu der
zeit zwischen 7 und 13 jahre alt laut
anklage geht es um 31 fälle drei davon
stuft die staatsanwaltschaft als schwer
ein das urteil könnte im januar fallen
bei einem busunglück südlich der
bulgarischen hauptstadt sofia sind 46
menschen ums leben gekommen darunter
zwölf kinder
der reisebus hatte eine leitplanke
gerammt dann überschlug er sich und ging
in flammen auf nur wenige der passagiere
aus nord mazedonien konnten sich aus dem
brennenden wrack befreien sie waren auf
dem rückweg von einer istanbul reise
für nichts gibt die europäische union so
viel geld aus wie für die agrarpolitik
und jetzt hat das eu parlament die
reform des milliardenschweren
europäischen agrar haushaltes
beschlossen dabei geht es darum die
landwirtschaft mit den klimaschutzzielen
der eu in einklang zu bringen unter
anderem sollen künftig 25 prozent der
direktzahlungen an die landwirte an öko
auflagen gekoppelt sein das geht vor
allem den grünen aber nicht weit genug
für andere ist die reform ein schritt in
die richtige richtung jetzt müssen noch
die mitgliedsstaaten zustimmen
politiker haben etwas was viele
unternehmen gerne hätten sachkenntnisse
und vor allem kontakte deshalb sollen
ehemalige eu-kommissar zwei jahre nach
ausscheiden aus der politik keine
berater jobs annehmen aber nach
zdf-informationen gehen viele ex
politiker lobby tätigkeiten nach was
kritiker fragwürdig finden und ganz
vorne auf der liste der ehemalige
deutsche kommissar oettinger florian neu
hand mit den einzelheiten
als ich die kommission und präsident
juncker 2009/10 in den ruhestand
verabschiedet gilt ab sofort eine regel
keine lobby jobs die nächsten zwei jahre
jedenfalls nicht ohne genehmigung diese
abkühlphase ist in wenigen tagen vorbei
eine auswertung die dem zdf exklusiv
vorliegt zeigt wie viele jobs sich die
ex kommissarin genehmigen ließen 32
allein bei firmen die offiziell als
lobbyisten in brüssel registriert sind
was kritiker nicht verstehen warum all
das genehmigt wurde die gefahr ist eben
dass die höchsten entscheidungsträger
der eu oder ehemaligen höchsten
entscheidungsträger im grunde zum
verkauf stehen dass man sich wenn man
genug geld hat kann man sich ehemalige
kommissare mieten um die eigenen
interessen zu vertreten an der spitze
der liste der deutsche ex kommissar
günther oettinger denn neben diversen
aufsichtsratsposten auch seine eigene
beratungsagentur in brüssel angemeldet
hat böttinger erklärt gegenüber dem zdf
ich kann für mich und nach meinem wissen
auch für meine kollegen sagen dass wir
die notwendige zurückhaltung gewahrt und
uns an die vorgegebenen regeln gehalten
haben
tatsächlich wurden die jobs von der
aktuellen kommission genehmigt wenn auch
mit auflagen etwa nicht bei der
kommission selbst zu lobbyieren erklärt
ein sprecher heute
niemand aber prüft ob diese bedingungen
eingehalten werden und es gibt
bedingungen die man nicht kontrollieren
kann etwa ob das wissen aus dem
kommissions- job genutzt wird und das
europaparlament will die aufsicht über
solche jobs künftig in die hände einer
unabhängigen ethik behörde geben
beschlossen ist das aber noch nicht
noch was in eigener sache
zdf-intendant thomas bellut ist mit dem
international emmy gewürdigt worden
einem ableger des wichtigsten
fernsehpreise der welt die auszeichnung
in new york überreicht von
basketballstar dirk nowitzki würdigt
bellut leistung als medienmanager und
die rolle des zdf während und nach der
wiedervereinigung
bellut betonte er sei in der glücklichen
position gewesen ohne druck von behörden
oder währungen arbeiten zu können etwas
das weltweit immer weniger journalisten
von sich sagen können
die farbe seiner stimme klang nach
whiskey und zigarettenrauch und war sein
markenzeichen volker lechtenbrink hat
sein talent vielseitig eingesetzt der
schauspieler sänger und theater
intendant ist gestern im alter von 77
jahren gestorben
seinen durchbruch als schauspieler hatte
er schon mit 14 in bernhard wickis
antikriegsfilm die brücke
danach mehr als 100 filme und
fernsehserien es hat seit mitte der 70er
jahre sang lechtenbrink und ein
multitalent mit dem faible für das
turbulente leben beweist auch dieser
song
die schon fürs lebens kenntnis hat die
mich während
wohnen wo es nicht lernen
runde die noch
schöne hohe wellen
[Musik]
und wir machen jetzt sportlich weiter
und mit kristin otto und da gibt es
quasi nur fußball champions league
endspurt in der vorrunde spannung in der
gruppe g der königsklasse denn jeder
verein aus dem quartett hat noch die
chance das achtelfinale zu erreichen so
auch der vfl wolfsburg der am abend beim
fc sevilla gewinde
der neue trainer hat bisher nahezu alles
richtig gemacht sagen die ergebnisse
nach der entlassung des glücklosen mark
van bommel vor vier wochen zeigt sich
die mannschaft in bundesliga und
champions league urplötzlich wieder von
ihrer besten seite wir haben nicht viel
zu verlieren aus unserer sicht sondern
wir können eine menge gewinnen und das
ist das was wir morgen auf dem platz
transportieren wollen eine gewisse
freude und aber auch eine gewisse hier
darauf weiter zu kommen coesfeld wird in
seiner strategie sicher eingeplant haben
dass sein team heute abend auf den
zwölften mann der sie viana auf den
dicht besetzten rängen treffen wird
personalsorgen bei leipzig rb muss
morgen im entscheidenden champions
league spiel gegen den fc brügge auf
torwart gulati und trainer marge
verzichten beide sind corona positiv im
fall markus anfang der wegen des
vorwurfs der impfpass fälschung als
trainer von werder bremen zurück
getreten ist ermittelt neben der
staatsanwaltschaft nun auch der
kontrollausschuss des deutschen
fußball-bundes ihm droht ein job verbot
hat werder trainer markus anfang seine
corona impfung vorgetäuscht und einen
gefälschten impfpass vorgelegt die
staatsanwaltschaft hat neue erkenntnisse
es ist jedoch zunächst einmal so dass in
diesem post weist zwei impfungen durch
das im zentrum köln dokumentiert sind
und nach mitteilung der insoweit
zuständigen kassenärztlichen vereinigung
sind die personaldaten des beschuldigten
dort in der edv nicht erfasst bei werder
bremen will man wieder mit sportlichem
erfolg punkten und zukünftig impf
debakel vermeiden
wir haben jetzt noch mal mit allen
spielern mit allen verantwortlichen
gesprochen wir haben auch jetzt noch mal
dann über das gesundheitsamt mit dem
gesundheitsamt die impf zertifikate
überprüft am ende ist es auch eine
eigenverantwortung
mögliches strafmaß für den beschuldigten
trainer geld oder haftstrafe bis zu
einem jahr
und ole werner soll wohl neuer
cheftrainer werden in bremen wir sind
gespannt dankeschön christin und esther
lee sagt ihnen gleich mehr zum wetter
das ist nämlich eher ruhig und bald
vielleicht auch weiß daherkommen kann
wir empfehlen das heute journal um 21.45
mit marietta slomka ja das war es von
uns wir sagen dankeschön fürs interesse
morgen begrüßt sie an dieser stelle
barbara hellwig machen sie's gut
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter hoher luftdruck
war heute wetter bestimmte über
deutschlands ein weiteres hoch dehnt
sich aus und wird kräftiger und dadurch
entsteht eine nördliche strömung aus dem
norden kommt in den nächsten tagen kalte
luft und die tiefs nehmen auch diese
zugbahnen und bringen sogar schnee mit
schauen wir die nacht in der kommenden
nacht im norden viele wolken nach süden
nebel teilweise klart es auch auf dort
wo die wolken fehlen wird es eine kalte
temperaturen von null bis minus 7 grad
in der südhälfte nach norden ist es
milder mit 8 grad am mildesten noch an
der nordsee morgen an der nordsee dann
viele wolken und etwas sprühregen und
vier worten in der nordhälfte im süden
aber dagegen sonnenschein und das bei
temperaturen von 1 grad bis 10 grad in
schleswig-holstein die kommenden tage am
donnerstag ist es größtenteils trocken
im norden etwas regen bei minus 1 bis 9
grad am freitag kommt von süden her
schnee auf unter der kann durchaus am
alpenrand kräftig sein ganz im norden
deutschlands dagegen regen bei minus 16
grad und samstag vor allem im westen
dann regen und schnee und ziemlich
ungemütlich ein schöner abend